just as a point of principle do you
think that we send too many people to
jail I think that we do have to have a
look at some of the people are being
sent to prison for a number of weeks for
example I'm not sure if it's in the
interest of the public purse or in the
interests of wider society for people to
be sent to prison for a number of weeks
for not paying the council tax or not
paying there the TV license is of course
people who are a dangerous violent
criminals that need to be in prison and
there are some people of course who will
never come out of prison and quite right
- - but I think that the Lord Thomas the
former Lord Chief Justice was correct
when he said in some offenses we do need
to look out in his words tough and I
mean tough community sentences as an
alternative what's clear at the moment
is our prisons are in disorder
what's clear at the moment is that all
too often prison prisoners ruin the show
prison officers are being attacked on a
daily basis prisoners are being attacked
by other inmates on a day just on that
point mr. Morgan what if given I think
it's at an average of 19 assaults a day
on on prison officers given that why
shouldn't prison officers routinely be
issued with stab vest tasers spray rigid
cuffs like that that's not labor policy
at the moment well we talked to the
prison officers Association on the
prison Governors Association and they
don't think by the way that that would
in of itself solve the problems one of
the big problems is under stuffing it's
hard for prison staff to keep order when
there are so few of them in there I'll
use that Liverpool that as an example
the staff - inmate ratio at Liverpool
used to be one in 30 or one to thirty
it's now one 200 has been one to a
hundred that's very hard to keep order
in those circumstances and the
conditions in our prisons have sucked go
I've got so bad for staff they
experienced prison officers leaving in
the droves I've visited I visit many
prisons and one of the prisons I visited
last summer half of the prison officers
in there had been prison officers for
less than a year dealing with very
difficult
and indeed in some cases dangerous
prisoners